sur ce plateau didier destro mot vient
de nous rejoindre bonjour vous êtes
ancien diplomate et auteur du roman de
la syrie aux éditions du rocher
les autorités françaises
ce qu'elles ont été efficaces parce
qu'elles ont arrêté cet homme là où est
ce que il ya eu des failles puisque on a
entendu on a à bouder leur poser cette
question comment at il pu passer au
travers du filet je crois qu'il faut pas
être plus royaliste que le roi
il faut déjà se féliciter que lui été
arrêté et que j'espère j'espère que les
autres les autres troupes qui sont déjà
en france il va y en avoir quand même
des masses nous serons un de ces jours
mais il faut se souvenir que la question
des prisonniers libérés n'est pas
nouvelle
tout prisonnier peut avoir été mis dans
une boucle anti nanti nationale c'est à
dire que quand ap détient un prisonnier
ou des prisonniers il peut très bien le
retourner contre son pays le libérer le
pays de l'acceptent
rappelez vous après après 45 tous les
prisonniers soviétiques
en allemagne ont été libérés et les
russes les soviétiques les ont acceptées
pour les mettre en sibérie où les
descendre donc la question des
prisonniers libérés à s'est toujours
posée de tout temps on sait concerne les
djihadistes moi j'ai régénérer pas par
quatre chemins
j'estime que quel que soit leur âge même
pour les enfants peut-être pas pour les
bébés ils constituent une menace
potentielle pour le pays dont ils sont
originaires
et qu'en conséquence il faut pas les
rapatrier
comme ça simplement parce que ils ont
une affinité du pays lui pose la
problématique du retour des djihadistes
européens en europe justement quelle
politique de la france et quelle
politique à l'échelon européen puisque
là le programme erasmus est un programme
d'études en europe mais il ya les bons
apôtres et aussi les juristes qui
estiment qu'un français quelle que soit
donc vous dans quel pays qu'ils soient
ou qu'est ce qui les fait a le droit de
revenir dans son pays
moi je trouve que notamment dans le
contexte actuel il faut se garder
d'appliquer cette règle pour l'ensemble
je crois qu'il faut comme l'a dit notre
mise affaires étrangères faire en sorte
que là où les crimes ont été commis
là ils seront jugés il avait jugé en
revanche peut-être que pour certains qui
promettent tous qu'ils s'engagent à
coopérer avec les autorités de police ou
de services spéciaux on peut ramener on
peut les ramener pour les exploiter
entre guillemets bien évidemment pour
faire en sorte que ils diffusent leurs
connaissances du milieu
oui donc et ils ont travaillé dans
lequel ils ont lutté qui donne des
renseignements généraux ou très haut ou
très ponctuelle est en fait en tirer en
tirer plus profit est parti peut-être
que que dans ce cas là on connaîtrait
mieux le mieux j à 10
vous pourrez mieux repérer aussi ceux
qui sont déjà revenus dans leur pays en
france pour nous et donc arrêté
également
donc il faut ne pas avoir une vision
trop globale est trop général de cette
question des djihadistes soi disant
repenti qui veut revenir dans leur pays
après avoir commis pour certains
décrient en succursale et femmes les
enfants
pour moi le problème quasiment le même
c'est un peu cruel de dire ça c'est
peut-être un petit peu
c'était peu chrétien de dire ça aussi
mais je pense qu'il faut mettre
pratiquement tout le monde dans le même
panier
même s'il est jamais tu qu'ils ont fait
des fautes et qui sont repentent ils
sont toujours potentiellement dangereux
le droit la deuxième chance ça n'existe
pas la deuxième chance oui mais si c'est
une deuxième chance sur huit mois je
crois qu'un pays comme la france dans
l'état actuel de la situation
internationale sécuritaire nationale on
peut pas s'offrir le luxe d'offrir une
d'une deuxième chance systématiquement à
tout le monde
pour revenir sur le plan européen et ce
programme d'études européen erasmus
puisqu'ils
il est rentré comme cela en europe est
ce qu'on peut dire que les djihadistes
ont infiltré ce réseau ou est ce qu'il
ya un problème au niveau de la sélection
des étudiants comment expliquer que cela
se produit je crois que dans ce cas là
on verra un peu plus tard le djihadiste
en question à cheveux changer d'identité
s'est présentée sur notamment en va
différemment avec tout ce qu'il faut là
aussi si vous versez dans un note dans
un pays comme étudiant un demande de
participer à erasmus comme visiblement
il est intelligent actifs qui connaît
plusieurs langues qui l'a peut-être fait
les études initiales on verra ça et est
ce que ça veut dire que les les
institutions européennes telles que
rasmussen ou autre ou des institutions
françaises doivent faire appel à des
services externes pour bien vérifier
l'identité des personnes qui se
présentent peut-être que cet exemple le
prouve
erasmus ne traite que des étudiants ce
n'est pas du tout un système sécuritaire
il il n'a pas inclus dans le système
erasmus
une étude de cas par cas du passé un
réel de tel ou tel individu donc
peut-être que cet exemple un va amener
les autorités de bruxelles qui s'occupe
d'erasmus de desserrer un peu plus les
boulons pour faire en sorte que ce drame
se répète pas c'est le mot de la fin
merci didier destremau d'avoir éperonné
une question je rappelle que vous êtes
ancien diplomate et auteur de l'ouvragé
l'euro jean de la syrie aux éditions du
rocher